kylie jenner and travis scott's
two-year-old daughter stormy webster
just slid into our instagram feed
literally and it's the freaking cutest
thing you'll see all day
thank you on sunday the 23 year old
kylie cosmetics founder shared
this clip of her little girl straight up
shredding toddler style on the slopes
[Music]
you went
give me high five that was amazing
but seriously that was amazing
naturally kylie was one proud mama and
captioned the cute clip quote
my little pro
[Music]
give me high five that was amazing
and if you thought that was impressive
let's go back to december 2019 real
quick
when stormy was just 22 months old kylie
shared this clip of the little one
dominating that snow like the boss baby
she is
ghost army ghost army ghost army go
stormy
22 months guys 22 months
yay big girl
but that tiny pink helmet though such a
cutie
it's fun but back to stormy's recent
skills
the family trip to aspen comes less than
two weeks after stormy joined her dad
travis scott
to help with the charity food and toy
drive ahead of christmas
the contactless drive-up event took
place at sunnyside park in houston
the same neighborhood that the 28 year
old musician grew up in
the event helped present 2000 toys to 1
000
students across three local elementary
schools
and the faculty and local residents
serving a
whopping 2 000 people total yeah
i did the math i'm excited about it and
stormy's mommy kylie
was all about it posting this pic to her
insta story and writing
big girl supporting her daddy at his
christmas food and toy drive
clearly the only thing more heartwarming
than stormy's snowboarding skills
is her big heart
you